well firing an AR is obviously a lot of
fun but it's not very concealable those
liberals don't like that one very much
Hickok 45 here glad to see that you're
all having a good time at the USC CA
Expo sorry I couldn't have made it but I
figured I would give you my impressions
of not scientific reviews now some of my
favorite concealed carry firearms
we should take this time to thank buds
gun shop for sponsoring the video and of
course we will be shooting Federal
Premium ammo let's put our ears in in
the try firing the old Walter PPS let's
see if mr. Gong is awake oh well it
shoots pretty good it's not ideal for my
larger hands but people who own their
Walters they love him it's clearly a
well-made firearm high quality and many
of you out there who own Walters love
him
so let's move on to another very popular
concealed carry choice a little more
expensive mind you but a favorite the
brand of our Special Forces the Sig p9
38 let's see what we can hit out here
let's go for a 2-liter oh forgot to put
my ears in yeah
safety first okay mr. 2-liter it seems
to shoot pretty good
oh let's see out there if you can see
awful ways there's a terrorist let's see
if we can wake up mr. jihadi well we
killed him as you can see it shoots
pretty good a smaller firearm but we did
execute a terrorist with it so uh no
complaints let's move on to the Ruhr SP
101 snub nose now you didn't really
think I was gonna do a video without a
wheel gun did you and I can see the
comments a lot of people saying Hickok
why would you give up that capacity but
it's the price that some people are
willing to pay for reliability let's
take a few shots with it and see if I'm
as accurate as I am with the semi-auto
let's go for a 2-liter it seems to be
shooting a little low the point of aim
let me see with another mr. cowboy here
oh no um that seems to be shooting
pretty good looks like I was the one
shooting little vain you know it's it's
always the sides and that how we usually
tell it let's see if we can hit that fly
out there or I guess I should say a gnat
is a proper term
about four klicks out let's see mr. net
if we can hit a nuts testicles
well we castrated him which is uh out of
a two and a half inch barrel about as
good as you can ask for well yeah that's
it
he brought a friend and it didn't work
out too well for him that's what you can
accomplish with a quality firearm if you
do your job it will do its job speaking
of which let's end on the ever-popular
kel-tec is that a toy or real firearm
many people find themselves asking but
no that's a real firearm many people
rely on that on a day to day basis and
there have been one or two perps you've
been taking town by this so let's see oh
I need to put my ears on let's see if
mr. gong is awake well a little blowback
there many people not aware of that with
the lighter caliber recoil can be stout
if it's a smaller frame a lot of people
I know I can see the comment section
saying you know it's the firearm but you
know a lot of people really love their
kill ticks I've had him for a while I
shot him pretty good
I think of anything it's proofed it to
firearms safety is paramount
that it can with if the seal is broken
hey if you liked this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you didn't like this video you should
subscribe anyway because then you can
watch the next video and what you can do
is down vote it and leave a comment
that's really negative you know
particularly if it's something like I
don't know maybe anti somatic even
though I'm not Jewish or something about
my hair or something about my weird nose
just leave a really negative comments
that everyone else around connect like
big care